in this course you will improve your
html css and javascript skills by
building a portfolio website hello
everyone in today's video we're going to
be building a portfolio website using
html css and javascript
so this is the main home page of the the
portfolio
okay so we have some nice have effects
on the buttons and the images
we can also toggle between light and
dark theme
okay so the next section is going to be
the about section we're going to have
some information
with also nicer effects and we're going
to have some stats here with progress
bars
and now we're also going to have a
timeline
okay so it also looks nice on the light
frame
okay and then the next section is going
to be
the portfolio section with the nasa
effect one of these patterns can lead us
to any website that
that you link it to
okay so for example if you want to get
to github you can click and then it goes
to github or youtube whatever
okay and then the next section is going
to be the block section
we also have a nice have effect on
images and the blog item
okay
so yeah
there it is and then finally with the
contact section
you can put your contact information
here
anything that you want it's up to you
this website is also responsive it's
going to support multiple screens you
can even make it more responsive as much
as you want
so when i decrease the width it's going
to
check those controls here and then put
them down here you can sort of you know
switch between the pages within the
controls down here instead of them to be
on the right side
okay so as you can see everything's
going to respond nicely
to different screen sizes
okay
so
same as the about it's going to
be nicely responsive
and also the portfolio it's going to be
nicely responsive
yeah also everything is responsive so
i'll show you everything out to make it
even more responsive you have the
knowledge to
make it different so
yeah i think that's it for this quick
demonstration i'll see you in the video
i have an images folder here so there
isn't many images so these are the
images that we're going to be using this
project i'm going to start by creating a
new html file
index.html
and then i'm going to create a new
folder so this one is going to be
storing all of our styles
inside the styles folder i'm going to
create a new style
so the extension we're going to be using
for this one is scss
so that's uh the sas preprocessor
it's much quicker to do styles than
normal css so to be able to use sas you
need to go to the extensions
and look for sas
and then you're going to find this sas
and then install that and also there's a
live compiler so we don't need to
restart every time that we
make updates to the code so we can just
uh
compile the code live okay
so now i you might also want to download
html and css snippets
so if you check html css support just
install this too
okay i think that's it for now uh we
just need to go to the styles and let's
do basic page resetting
so i'm going to set the margin to zero
because by default the page is gonna
have a margin
and padding zero
box sizing
zero butter box actually blur box and
then
list style
to none
okay so in the body i'm just going to
give it a background color
of red just to check out if our styles
are working
so uh we need to
compile this sauce file inside the stars
folder so here you're going to see
a button says watch sas click that
button
okay and then it's going to generate a
star css
file here
so let's go to the index and generate
html boilerplate so
to do that hold shift and one
and then click enter
shift hold shift one enter
okay so i'm gonna i'm going to name this
portfolio
portfolio okay so now i'm just going to
link
the
style css file styles
start with css so
i'm going to run this with the live
server so you can go to the extensions
and look for live server plug
extension
okay so
i'm going to
run this now
with the live server
there it is
okay so that means our styles are
working so i'm going to get rid of the
background color of red
i'm going to get rid of that
i am going to
actually get some fonts first
google phones
google phones i'm gonna get the
phone call poppins
okay so you need to select some font
weights so and
we're going to be using regular 400 500
400
500 the regular ones only all the way to
800. so once you've done that you just
need to copy this
the link
once you've copied uh go to the index
below the styles and then paste in the
font weights
okay so i'm also going to copy the font
family name and then i'm going to put in
the body
okay so now that we've done the fonts
we're going to
be able to toggle between dark and light
mode so to do that we're going to be
using some variables some css variables
so to do variables
i'm going to type root
and then we're going to put some
variables inside the root okay
so the mainly the variables we're going
to do for the colors
okay so you can do a variable literally
for anything but for mainly in this
video i'm going to do colors so the
first one is going to be
color primary
and so the color primary is going to be
like a dark color
191
and then uh d
2b i think that's the color
yeah
okay so that's the color i'm going to
paste in the rest of the colors because
i don't waste your time typing the
colors one by one
okay so these are the variables that
we're going to be using
so now for the body i'm going to give it
a background
color to be able to use the variable you
do va
primary so va primary color we're going
to be utilizing this variable
which is a color a dark one
okay so i'm going to also do a font size
a default font size it's going to be one
point
one ram so that's going to be our
default font size
um
also i'm going to
give it a different color
the different color is going to be white
so by default i want the text to be
white okay and then i want also the
transition
transition so the transition is going to
be 0.4 seconds easy and ease out
okay so like that so now that we've done
that let's go to the
index
so in here i'm going to give the body
class of main
content so main content so that's the
body
and then in the body we're going to have
a header
a header with a class of section
and then another another class name of
such sec one section one
and then another class of header
and then uh it's going to have another
class of active you're going to see why
we're using active i'll explain later as
we go
press enter
okay so now we have the header
and then let's go to your main
in the main we're going to have section
dot section
uh section is going to have a class of
section and then dot another class
section two
and then another class about
okay
so now i'm gonna click enter so now we
have a section
okay so we're going to have
five more sections
okay so we have uh section section two
about so this is that's that's the class
name i'm going to uh duplicate this
uh two more three more times one two
three
okay so
it's going to all of them are going to
contain a class of section all of them
i'm just going to change this from
sector to sec3
section 4 and section 5.
okay you can just change the class names
here from
about to portfolio
and then the other one this one's going
to be blogs
and then this one is going to be contact
contact okay
so that's that
now we have the sections uh we need to
let's start by styling all these
sections
before we add any content let's work on
the functionality to switch
between the sections okay using the
javascript
i'm going to
uh introduce you to front awesome i'm
gonna say font
or some cdn
cdn
and then look for the front of some cdn
look for the version
version 5.
5.1 and then copy the link tag
and then go below the google fonts
uh even above and then just paste in the
link
okay
so now we've pasted the link for fonts
and font awesome we can you know like
sort of get icons from front or some
phones awesome
instagram let's say we want to use the
instagram icon
so we can copy this instagram icon let's
see if it's working i'm just going to
paste it down here and when i save let's
see
in the preview if it's working or not
let's see
there it is so that means it's working
so it's white as well that's the
different color of the website
and the icon is working so that means
photoshop is installed successfully
so now
uh let's start by installing the
sections okay
i'm also gonna going to target all of
the links the anchor tags i'm gonna say
display line block
line block and then
text
decoration
to none and then i'm going to say
i'm going to
actually give it
um
what's this i forgot the name color
color is going to be inherited so we're
going to inherit the color we have in
the body and then font family it's going
to be inherit
and here it is uh
okay so now
does that uh let's go start each
individual section so these sections
we're going to be able to switch between
the sections
because of the positioning they're going
to have they're going to have a position
of absolute
so each section is going to have a
minimum height of 100 vh
okay so that's the minimum height and
then a width
of 100
and then we're going to do position of
absolute and then we're going to do left
zero
top to zero is our
top zero
and then we're going to do padding so
padding is pacing so top and bottom the
spacing between top and bottom is going
to be three ram and then 18 ram left and
right
okay so each and every second is going
to have this these styles okay
and actually we need to also do the
header
so the header is going to have a height
a fixed height of 100 vh so the height
for the head is going to be fixed
okay
and then we're going to do a color the
color for that is going to be
uh white color
white for the
color
white i don't know i didn't auto
complete and then uh we're also going to
have
an overflow
of heating just in case something
overflows
okay so now
nothing happens uh when i inspect this
we have all of this all of those
sections that on top of each other okay
because we're using position of absolute
so now they're all laying in top of each
other so to create the effect of uh
switching between these sections we need
a way to hide the rest of the sections
and then only display the one that we've
clicked on
okay we're going to do that later in
javascript but now let's keep going
i'm going to target the section class
so this section class i'm gonna do so by
default i wanted to
be away from the screen i want it to be
off screen
okay so i'm going to use the transformer
for that and then i'm going to translate
to y
minus 100
it was by default i want it to be off
screen
okay and then i'm also going to do a
transition
you can create a variable for this
transition actually if you want because
i'm going to reuse this a lot of times
in this video so you can you know make
it easier by creating a variable for
that
okay so now we have a transition
and also we need a background color
so for this one it's going to have a
va
primary color
primary color okay so that's that's the
one
so
each individual sections we can style
them differently we can give them a
different background color a different
whatever so i'm going to target section
one
sect one sec one
so this second one you can give it a
different background color if you want
to but by default i want it to be none
the display i don't want to display
anything because i want to be able to
switch between these sections
okay i'm going to do transform as well
translate
translate y
actually it's y i want to translate y
zero for now and then
now we're going to do scale
we're going to do one
okay so now when we this section is
active
it's going to come back to the default
place so here we we did uh transform
translate y minus 100
and scale which is zero here
so
uh once we come back to the default
place it's gonna
you know it's gonna make like an
animation coming in
off screen and scaling all the way to
one so the scale works from one zero two
between zero
and one
okay so we need to do this for the rest
of the sections so i'm just going to
paste in some codes for the
for the rest of the sections so this
sections each individual section you can
give it a different background color
okay
you can kind of you know give it a
different background color just to
see your to your liking
okay nothing much nothing much happens
here nothing much so now for now let's
uh let's do the buttons which are going
to let us control these sections
so these buttons i'm gonna
do dot controls
so make sure
controls
i'm pretty sure this is the wrong
spelling but it doesn't matter so inside
the controls we're going to have the
buttons okay so each individual button
is going to have a class of control so
i'm gonna do dot control
control
so that's a button it's gonna have a
control and then it's gonna have a
control one so the first one is gonna be
control one the second one control two
control three and so on so i'm gonna say
control
so this one is control one i'm going to
use the dollar sign
so the dollar sign means uh increment
the numbers automatically depending on
how many classes on how many divs we've
created
okay
so ctrl and then it's going to have
another class of
uh
actually it's not going to have any
other class and i'm just going to hit
enter
actually i'm just gonna
put a class of active btn so that's the
first one's gonna have a class of active
pattern i'm going to multiply this by
five
okay
so uh we don't need active button on the
rest of the divs okay so you can like
get rid of this we only want the first
one to have um
active button so we have ctrl control
one ctrl two three all the way to five
okay so inside each of these uh divs i'm
going to put a corresponding icon so in
this case you can go to font or some and
then you can for example search let's
say
home you can look for an icon that you
are looking for in this case this one
and then you're just gonna copy this
and then you paste it in
like so so that's the icon we're looking
for
i'm just gonna paste in the
this data instead of me doing one by one
okay so we're using one briefcase
newspaper envelope open
i'll get rid of this so i'll explain
later
okay so now i'm gonna save this
as you can see with the icons there they
are
so for us we want these icons to be here
on the right side so to do that we're
going to be using
position of fixed because we want it to
be at a fixed position
okay so uh we're going to target the
controls
you can make a comment you can say
controls
controls and then here you just do
dot control
okay so this is the parent so position
i'm going to do personal fixed so that's
the parent container and then the index
is going to be 10 because i want it to
be always at the top
and then i'm going to do top 50
okay and then right it's gonna be three
percent
so wanted to be
aligned
to leave a space of uh
three percent from the right so there
they are so now they're leaving three
percent of space from the right side
okay so now we're going to do display
flex
flex direction
column
and then we're also going to
i think we might be able to
uh give them a font size some sometime
later but i want to actually center this
in the y axis
so to center this in the y
we can do transform translate y
minus 50
to center this in the wire so as i save
as you can see there they now they've
updated they've now nicely centered
okay
so we've uh kind of
centered i'm gonna do align items
to center
and then justify content
to center as well
okay so i'm going to target
the control class
control
control class so for the control class
i'm going to give it a padding so it's
like spacing around it so this spacing
is going to be one of them and then the
cursor is going to be pointer
cursor pointer and then i'm going to
give it a background color
uh background color is going to be
so it's going to be 4 grade 4
so it's going to be grateful
so that's the background color so width
and height is going to be
55 pixels because i want it to be
rounded so with the knight has to be the
same if you want to make something
around it so the border radius is going
to be 50 to make them rounded
okay so as you can see now they're
around it but i want to center these
icons they're not centered nicely
so to do that we're just going to use uh
flex it's easy display flex and align
and just the content to center
okay so i'm also going to make a spacing
between these icons
so this spacing that we're going to use
is margin so top and bottom is gonna
point b point four zero yeah point seven
ram and then zero left and right
okay also we're going to give a box
shadow
box shadow we might also want to
put this box shadow in a variable to be
honest
uh i'm gonna
create a
here i'm gonna say box
shadow
i don't know shadow
one
and then these are the values so zero on
the x-axis three pixels from the y
fifteen pixels uh for the play and then
the opacity is zero point three
okay so this is the box shadow that
we're going to be using
i'm just going to do a ver
and then i'm just going to paste in the
variable
just in case we don't like redo this box
shadow because i'm going to be reusing
this workshop a lot in this video
okay so
there they are they're showing nicely
so i want to also resize this icon the
icon size so to do that i'm going to
target the i which is the i inside the
icon
if you don't already know about sas we
can nest in the
elements okay so we can nest some html
elements so that's what i'm doing right
now so i'm gonna say font size
i'm gonna put this to 1.2 ram i want it
to be slightly bigger and then i'm gonna
also
give it a color
and pointer events of none so pointer
events it means i don't want to click if
when i click i don't need to do anything
it doesn't react to the
click or to the mouse whatever
okay so now with let's save everything
looks nice everything looks on point
okay so now i'm going to
so if you remember here i've given this
a class of active button
so the whatever button i want this
active class
to be applied to whatever element that
i've clicked on and also at the same
time remove other elements with that
class okay so when i click this i want
only this button to have that class
active button active pattern and then
remove the remaining active buttons
class names
so
uh
that function that features a little bit
tricky for you know for beginners but
it's actually easy to do
so what we're going to do now actually
i'm going to style the active button
first
so
whatever active button
so in here
above the control i'm going to say dot
active button i'm gonna style that so
it's just giving it a background color
and the transition
okay like so background color is gonna
be the secondary color which is the
green color and then i'm going to target
the icon inside it
the eye
so i'm gonna just
target the icon and give it a color of
white
okay so there it is so that's the active
button
it seems like everything is nicely
centered now yeah so now the active
button is going to be green
okay
so now that actually button is green we
just need to
go to the javascript and let's create a
new javascript file actually so let's do
new file it's going to be up
to js so this object.js i'm going to
select
some html elements
so i'm going to select all items or
elements using the section class so
const sections document the query
selector query selector oh
everything that shares the class of
section so as remember we've given all
all of these sections a class of section
so it means i'm selecting everything
with the class of section
so i'm targeting this
i'm also going to select
um
i'm also going to select the bat section
buttons so the section buttons is the
parent container of this
of these buttons so the controls so
these are the section buttons so it's
like the parent i'm selecting this
parent container and then inside i'm
going to also select the each individual
button with a class of control
okay
so
um i'm just gonna
okay so there is a section button
controls so this is the parent this is
the actual button
i'm also going to select
the body the body is a class of main
content
so there is the body main content that's
the class
okay so in here i'm just going to create
a new function i'm going to use the
actual function function to create a new
function and then i'm going to say page
transition
transitions maybe you can name this
function whatever you want it's up to
you really
so now i'm going to
comment here i'm going to say
uh button
click
active class
active class okay so what what do i want
to happen when i click the button
so this i want to be able to get rid of
the class uh that is not active only the
active class that's that's what i want
to have the class one
so we're going to do a loop we're going
to do four
so
we're going to do let we're going to
create a new variable so let i
okay so it's going to be initially
set to zero and then we're going to say
i
is less than as long as i is less than
is is less than
the length the length of the the button
okay
the section
btn so section btn
is this one
okay so as long as the
si is less than that
we're going to increment
increment
all right
so now that's that so in here i'm going
to say
uh
select button
so the sec sec button
i'm going to look for the index
the i
okay whatever index we're on and then
i'm going to say this goes to
actually i want to add an event listener
to whatever index we've clicked on
so the this i is the index okay so i'm
going to say dot add event listener
so the event listener is going to take
to
the first one is going to be click and
then the second one is going to be a
callback function
so yeah what am i doing
this one is going to be a quebec
function so in in this callback function
okay so in this call i'm going to select
the current button
whatever button we've clicked on the
current button
you can button one current btn and then
i'm going to say it goes to
document so we're going to do query
selector
with a class of active button
okay so if you remember the buttons are
going to have a classroom active
btn
okay so i'm selecting that it's a cut
it's with the
name of current button so i'm going to
say current button
the first one
with an index of zero i'm going to set
your class name
then i'm going to say current btn index
0
and then i'm gonna do class name
i'm going to not list class
name and then i'm going to replace that
with an empty string
uh once we're out of the
once it's not active
active
b
tn
and then i'm going to
replace with an empty string
okay so
uh whatever button we've clicked on uh
when we're not collecting clicking it
anymore we're going to
get rid of the class and replace with
the empty string so here i'm going to do
this
dot uh class name
so this uh is referring to this function
okay so this is like a confusing topic
to learn about the this keyword in
javascript
it's a kind of weird and then i'm going
to do plus equal to
active button
active
vtn
okay like
that so now when i save
uh we need to call this function
page transitions
so let's call the function let's go
actually we also need to link this
javascript file we're going to do script
script
and then we're going to
do source
and then app.js
and then let's save save everything and
then go to the page inspect
and then when we click this button
hopefully a class should should appear
on whatever button we've clicked on and
then it's going to get rid of this
active button here
okay
that's a start
we have an
error but we're going to
so it didn't work so when i click the
class is off but it's not working let me
inspect what's going on
cannot read properties of a undefined
class name
okay i'm pretty sure i see this one this
keyword
class name does replace
okay something is wrong
list
oh this note cloud is supposed to be
class name not list
okay so let's save this uh hopefully
if you work click
nothing happens we have an error again
undefined
that's weird
current btn class name
replace
active btn so you just need to make sure
let me double check maybe
just double check to see if the namings
are correct i'm just going to copy and
paste and replace everything
query selection
actually but i think the naming is
correct
okay let's try to figure out what's
going on
undefined oh
current button
it is button
okay
the class naming is correct
document query selector
all
i don't get what's undefined here
um i just realized something i didn't i
didn't find the error but
i'm not
uh supposed to use an arrow function
here i'm pretty sure
i'm supposed to use a regular function
i'm gonna
do function
like that instead of
because this keyword doesn't exist in an
arrow function
okay so it only exists
on the regular function oops what did i
click
okay so now let me just double check
from recording
only right after i stopped the video
that's when i realized that i've used
the
arrow function
okay so when i go to console
okay everything works fine so now it's
uh
it's working as expected
only so don't use other functions for
the
if you want to use this keyword it
doesn't exist in arrow functions okay
so
so now let's uh let's move on to the
next step to the next step
so for the next stage let's start
actually
doing the content but to be able to do
that we need to be able to cycle between
these sections
okay so now we've done the active class
for the button
so now we need to do the content
so
uh each button is going to have
something called a data id
and then this data id
so when i click the button it's going to
look for a section with this id so in
this case it's going to look for the
about section
with an id of about portfolio about
portfolios blogs and contacts so make
sure you add the data id
next to the
next to the
uh to the class after the class and then
here i'm going to also add a data id so
this one is going to be
uh
the header
so this one is going to look for the
header
actually we can do main or home
it's up to you home
okay
so i'm gonna give the ids so do id
uh so this one is gonna be home so give
the corresponding id make sure this id
matches the data id here so for the home
the first one the first button is going
to be home the second one is about
about
so this section about section
i'm going to id
id so this one is going to be about
and then this third one
id
port
folio
and then id
this one is going to be
blogs
and then finally we have contact
id
contact
okay so these ids are going to help us
navigate through these sections
okay so now that we have those id's
um
we've done these sections let's let me
inspect this section
they are there by the right on top of
each other if we go main
uh these sections they're there
actually
we need to
style these are different background
colors
uh
okay
you know what we i'm gonna give them
different background color background
color
slightly blue so you can see the
difference but we don't see them yet
because the scale scale is zero
and uh actually translate is minus 100
so they're off screen and the scale is
zero as well so you don't see them
yet so we just need to do a little bit
of javascript
so we'll be able to see them later on
all right
it's just for you to see these uh
sections
okay i'm going to save this
so we don't uh see these sections so now
we just need to
do the active class
so
when we click each button it's going to
do an active class
okay so the active class is going to be
the active class is going to be added
to the sections okay
so here i'm gonna say
uh
sections
active
class
okay so we have all sections we are
selecting all of these sections here so
this section
is targeting so this the main content
here
is the body
okay so the body
that's the
all of this section it's like a parent
of all of these sections
so i'm going to say
all the sections all of these sections
dot for reach so i'm going to loop over
whatever is inside them the body
okay
so in this case
all of these sections are inside the
body
so it's going to take in a cobalt
function i'm going to say section
okay so
we have section
actually we need to add an event
listener
we will look through later add event
listener
and then when i click inside uh
once i click
okay so
yeah you can
do a cover function here and then we're
going to take an event so the e is for
the event
okay so i'm gonna i'm just going to say
e
control log here i'm gonna say e
dot
target okay so i'm gonna save
let's go to the console let me just
click anywhere
so it's not doing anything yet because
the sections are outside
okay so
you want you want you won't see it but
now it's targeting whatever element of
it's console logging any element that
i've clicked on
as you can see
and then it's showing the class or
whatever element and the name of
whatever element i've clicked on
okay so we're just adding event lists
now to whatever element but in this case
we want to target these buttons here
okay
so
let's get rid of this
so in here i'm going to say const id
and then we're going to say it goes to e
to a target
dot data set
data set
like this and then dot id
so
the data set
is like referring to whatever
i've clicked on whatever element i've
clicked on the target
what going to target the data set so the
data side is this one
here
we we gave a data id here so whatever
element that i've clicked on i'm going
to target the data set whatever
element i've clicked on
especially these buttons i won't target
the data set for that
so i'm going to get uh take the names of
these data sets here
okay
so that's what this is referring to so
i'm like taking the data set and put it
into a variable called id
okay so i'm going to say
if
if ids was true or if we have an id or
whatever
we're going to do
i'm going to first remove the
remove
selected
select head
from the other button
okay like that something like that so
here i'm going to do section buttons
which is the container of the buttons
but i want to look through each
individual button inside
okay so to do that we're just going to
do with for each
so each button
so for each button i'm going to do btn
each button
the class list
class list and then i'm going to remove
the class of active pattern active
actually
active active button is a different
class for the styling of the buttons but
this is a class referring to so this
active class we're going to use this for
these sections
not the active
styles like this so this this different
thing different class name
okay so
we're looking through the button each
individual button
uh if we're not clicking the button
we're just getting getting rid of the
class
and then we're just going to say e to a
target
and then we're going to say class list
we just want to add the class to
whatever pattern that we've clicked on
so here i'm just going to do uh either
target.classlist
uh the e is gonna is coming from here
the event
okay so we're going to add a class of
active
okay so now that we've added the class
um
i'm also going to hide
uh other sections
other sections as well
as we're doing it so we we've done that
already but like i'm just
gonna do that
sections
so this we're not seeing the sections
yet but when i click the active button
i want to be able to
set the display and the
translate translation
back to default okay
so i'm going to do sections
i'm going to do dot for each
section so if you remember the sections
it's coming
here from the section
so each every section i'm looking
through every section
okay so
for every section i'm gonna say section
uh i'm gonna
section
the class list
add or remove
it's like the same thing that we've done
with the the button
and when i say active
all right
so uh
that's pretty much it actually down here
i'm just gonna do one more thing const
element
element and then here we're just going
to do document
document
and then i'm going to do dot get element
by d
element
by id
and then we're going to pass in the id
so whatever id
is coming from the data set is going to
be inside the element element element
variable we're saving the id
so remember here we give we gave the id
here
id about portfolio so whatever element
we're on we're going to pass in the id
and also
uh this data id is it's linked
to the to these ids
so whatever element we're on and then
we're targeting the id so now we're just
going to say element
you can name
and then we're going to do class class
list
and then we're also just going to add
active
okay
so now i'm gonna save
let's see what we have so let's inspect
to see our sections
so
home hopefully should have an active
class header we've edited this manually
but when i click something else
hopefully you should get rid of this and
put it somewhere else
when i click yeah it got rid of the
active class from the header now this
one is active
this about when i click
this one is active now it's getting rid
of the existing class one other
okay so now we can only use the active
on one element
but
we don't see our sections here
they are there but we don't see them
because they're hidden we just need to
uh display those uh
sections
so i'm gonna go
uh under 65
i'm just gonna do
dot active
so we're styling the active
um
display block so we only want to display
whatever
element is active okay
now let's save so now the header is
active it is a color of green
it's working
okay so everything
works we can circle through the sections
okay
but these sections they're not animating
no no that's not what we want so down
here i'm just gonna say
animation
i'm gonna say scale
anime so that's the name of the
animation the duration is going to be
one second
and then i'm going to have an easing and
ease out
so i'm going to do an animation down
here i'm going to do it keyframes
and then this one is going to be scale
anim so that's the name of the animation
scale on him and then i'm going to do at
zero percent what do i want is zero
transform
translate
late
transformed
transform
translate
what's going on zero percent
translate y
okay so for the y here
it's the same thing we've done before
scale
zero
okay so it's only gonna have two states
the ten percent zero percent and the
one hundred percent
okay
whoops
my mouse is broken by the way it double
clicks when i don't need to so when i
try to do a single click it double
clicks automatically i need to get a new
mouse
okay so here it's just resetting the
values to back to zero and the scale
back to one
okay let's save this
hopefully it should work now as you can
see
we can scale
okay we can sk but that's not the effect
we're looking for
uh we are looking for
scale y
okay so we're looking for scale y
okay we run the scale everything so we
want only to scale the y axis so when
the content come from you know up
as you can see now we can
you know do those effects
okay
that's it for the
effects now we can
uh scrub through the sections
i'm going to take a break now
and then i'll be back in a way i'm just
going to drink some water and then
we'll continue where we left off
okay i'm back so now let's uh
do the header so let's start the header
do the content inside the header and
then we'll move on to other sections
so for the header
we're only mainly going to have some
images and stuff
so here i'm going to do a class
header content
so the header content is going to have a
left and a side and the right
left header
and then we're going to have the right
header so the right side so because
we're going to display grid
okay so for the left side it's there's
there isn't nothing anything here it's
just an image
we're going to do header shape
and then below that
i want to do
an image
it's inside
image div
img
img
hero
that's the image name
and then
we go to the right side so here it's
just a bunch of text
so we're gonna have h1 with name
i'm just gonna paste in the name
okay so this pan is surrounding the name
because i want to color this color the
name
only this bit a different color that's
what i'm surrounding with this pan
okay
so this pan also have a class of name i
don't know why we have the same
i'm gonna get rid of the span class
class name i'm just going to surround it
like this like span
okay
below that uh we're
gonna have a p a p tag
oh i'm just gonna paste in some text as
well
i'm sorry about it i'm sorry about the
background noise my mates are
playing a video game
i'm gonna do a
dot
main
main btn
okay so that's an anchor tag so it's
going to have an icon
and it's going to have two spans this
the first pan is going to have a class
of
ptn text
okay so it's just text uh the text is
gonna say download cv
you can put any text that you want
so this is an anchor tag it's a link you
can make it go somewhere or to google
drive wherever you're saving your cv
or whatever
you can send it there and then another
span is going to have an icon for the
download icon coming from font awesome
okay so now that's it for the header
content we just need to do the styles
i'm gonna get rid of this green color
here so that was just for testing
purposes for you to see
to show you that the sections are
working i'm just going to get rid of
this
go read
i'm going to get rid of everything okay
so now we're left with the default
colors
so now let's start doing the header
so for the header content
after the controls i'm just going to say
header content
and the content and then i'm going to do
another duplicate this i'm gonna say
um
in the
patent
components
so some components that we might want to
reuse we're gonna put them down here
okay so now i'm gonna target header
content
header content so for the other content
we're going to do display of a grid
we're going to put a two column grid
grid template columns we're going to do
repeat i want to have two columns and
then one fr so they're all going to be
equal
so when i save so now we have two
columns when i inspect this
as you can see we have two columns one
two
okay so that's what we want
and then uh yeah the height is going to
be 100
with the height and then we're going to
target the
left
header left header
so for that
display
flex
align items
align items
align items to center
okay and then position it's going to be
relative because when the position
absolute a shape
that's going to be behind our image
so this image is save this
it's going to have a shape behind it
okay so that's
why we're doing the personal relative
different container so the shape we've
named that shape h
shape if you remember that's the header
shape uh the shape is gonna have a
transition that we've been using before
i'm just gonna paste in transition and
then a height of 100
with 65 percent
background color is going to
be going to be secondary color
it's going to be the background color
and then
position absolute and then we're going
to do left
0
top 0
top
zero
and then i'm going to do the index i
want it to be behind the image
of one minus one actually want it to be
behind
and then i'm going to do clear path
so i click path i'll show you what in
what it does i'll just
paste in the corner and then i'll show
you
so this is the click path these are the
values we're using for the clear path
it's like
uh altering the shape so to do that
we can do
clip path generator
and then we can generate kind of
a clear path
for example when this trapezoid
trapezoid the name it's kind of
confusing to read and then we can you
know generate the shape that we're
looking for and then we can just copy
this code
and then you can paste it wherever on
whatever shape you want to customize so
in this case these are the these are the
values that i'm using and then after
that after the shape i'm going to target
the image
so for the image i'm going to give it a
border radius
so the border radius is going to be va
i'm going to do
md i can't remember the border radius
small two so i'm using the better radar
small two is a variable
okay
i'm gonna do width and height
so width it's going to be ninety percent
uh
height 90 percent with 68 percent
and then in background color
background
color is going to be far
so the background color is going to be
black that's going to be the background
color and then the transition when the
ima to have a transition as well we've
used this transition multiple times and
then i'm going to target the image
inside the image container we have an
image the actual image
width and height it's going to be set to
100
okay and then object fit to cover so it
doesn't stretch out
object fit to cover
so this image is not going to stretch
out uh we also want to transition this
image again
copy this transition we're going to
reuse you can put that in there variable
so you don't have to copy and paste like
this
and then want this image to be in a
grayscale form so i'm going to say
filter grayscale
and then i'm going
put the
grace grayscale to 100 percent
and then when we have her
when we have the image
and have a
so this is the beauty of sas we can nest
components uh html elements and then
we're gonna say filter
uh grayscale
zero
okay let's save let's see what we get
okay so when i hover the image is
changing color
all right
uh
just gonna get rid of these
so now yeah they may see any color so
now let's go to the right side
so on to the
right side
it's mainly
so we have left header i'm going to
collapse the left header
i'm going to say right
header
okay so for the right header and when i
do display flex
this yeah
display
flex
flex direction
to column
because i want everything to be in a
column direction
okay and then just for content to center
and then padding right
uh it's going to put a large value here
18 ram i think that works name
then font size so for the name is the
main title i'm going to make it bigger
okay
and then i'm going to target this pan
inside it
so there's a span in there so this one
is going to have a color a different
color the color this color is going to
be a secondary color
color so that's the
color for that and then after the name
we have a paragraph
i'm going to give the margin top and
bottom is going to be 1.5 ram
and then left and right is going to be
zero
and then after that i'm going to give it
a line height so line it is the spacing
of lines of text so the liner is going
to be sort of like something like two
ram then i'm going to save let's see
what we get so there it is
looks nice uh we just need to start this
button
so to start the button we're going to
reuse this button so it's a independent
component
so i'm going to say dot
main
btn okay so this main btn actually it's
i think it's wise to put it into a
container dot btn container
like that
okay so now we can uh try we can start
styling the
main button
okay so
uh this button is gonna have a lot of
styles
okay so border radius it's going to be
30 pixels
i want it to be nicely rounded it's not
not 20
but 30.
okay
font
size i'm going to do color
inherit
and then i'm going to do font weight
it's going to be 600 i want the text to
be
thick
okay and then i'm gonna do position of
relative
and then i'm gonna give it a border with
one pixel and the color
of secondary that's the border
i'm gonna do display flex and align
everything to center
okay and then i'm going to say overflow
to hidden
okay
so inside the button we have ptn text to
a btn
text and then i'm just going to give it
a padding
top and bottom 0 to ram left and right
ok so in the button we also have a bit
we also have dot
btn
we have the icon
okay
ptn icon so if you don't remember the
class names
this one btn icon
okay so the btn icon it's gonna have a
color
of the green color secondary and then
center everything using flex
okay so we've done that over and over so
sometimes i'm just gonna have to copy
and paste
so to send everything just display flex
align item center just for content
center
so padding one room so it's like spacing
around
i'm gonna save let's see what we got
so there's our button
but it's filling in the entire width
because we're using flex on the parent
container so to get rid of this effect
we can do btncon
btn container if you remember we put in
the apparent container called btn cone
here there it is beaten corn we're just
going to do display flex on that display
flex
and then i'm going to say align
self
i'm pretty sure flex that
um
yeah like that
so now now now we need to hover and
bring in
something here when we have a and bring
in like a shape that
similar to a button so we're going to
use a
a suit element
a before suit element
we'll say end
before
and then we're going to say content to
an empty string
so we can start this to whatever styles
we desire
pressing absolute top zero
zero and then right is going to be
zero
right 0 and then we're going to do
transform
translate x
so we're going to take the shape away
from the button
minus 100 is gonna go like to this side
away from the button
minus 100
uh we're also going to do the transition
i'm just gonna
paste in the transition
and then i'm gonna do the index i want
it to be behind the text
of the button
minus one
okay
so now
this shape
uh it's there but it doesn't have a
width height anything defined
so i'm going to say
and
however when i hover the button
i have
the button i'm going to attack the
before suit element
and what do i need to what do i want to
happen i'm going to put your width and
height 100
and then the
set a background color to the secondary
color
okay so now when i inspect
let me inspect this
let's look for the before
it's there
the first element is there but
remember we are translating on the
x-axis minus
100 so we need to bring it back to the
default
position which is zero
okay when we have and then when we are
not hovering it's going to go back to
away from the button
so it's doing a weird
it's doing this effect from the wrong
direction
so it's it's from miners it's actually
100
because we're going 100
uh on the positive value minus is gonna
go negative
okay so i wanted to amend positive
so it's coming from the
right side now so it sees
but yeah there it is
i think we need to add a transition
somewhere
in here too we need a transition here as
well
so i'm gonna save
save it's gonna i don't know it's
glitching sometimes it glitches
it's not doing it
before
transition
oh yeah i think in the harvard that's
when we need the transition let's see
it's not doing it
if it doesn't it does if it doesn't work
it doesn't
oops not in the icon
okay it doesn't matter it works
okay so now what we need to do
is go into the next section
which is the about section
this about section it's a
it's a
it's just i just say it's too much
so much content there okay so i'm just
gonna go to the about
about let me check how long i've been
recording i'm so tired i've recorded
this video like a couple of times and
then
i made an error which was too bad i
couldn't even edit out so
now i'm gonna go to the about section
so on to the
i'm gonna collapse the controls
about
so in the about i'm gonna create a new
div called main title
so we want to be able to reuse this
title
it was true
so this is like a title with this pan
inside
it's like the main title
so we have
about me
and then we have a span covering the me
okay so i'm going to color this
differently so if we're surrounding
something with span
it means we're going to style that diff
that's that particular element
differently
okay so in the independent components so
we finish the button
now we need to do
main title
all right so
for the main title
uh it's just
text align to center
text align to center and then now we're
going to target the h2 the header
position relative and then we're going
to do
text transform uppercase
some uppercase and then we're going to
do
front white
font size first
for ram
front white is going to be 700
and then
that's it for now let's tuck these pans
so for this pan i'm going to do color
it's going to be
[Music]
it's going to be a secondary color
okay so after that we're going to target
bg
bg
text
so the bg text is going to have position
of absolute is going to be like behind
the main text
i'm going to say top
50
and then i'm going to do left
50 as well
and then we're going to do color a gray
color and then a transition
okay i'm just going to face it so
transition as usual z index minus one i
want it to be behind the
text okay and then the front weight
800
so this transform translate minus 50
minus 50 it means we want to center
something
okay
and then the font size
is going to be 6.3 ram
okay let's save this let's see what we
got
okay so there it is
okay so
about me
and then here says my stats in the
background
okay so now we have the main title the
big title
now let's
do that
about content so it's like a div that's
gonna contain
everything
about
container
container and then i'm gonna have a left
container left about in the right about
left and right
okay so uh we're going to have an h4 in
the paragraph i'm just going to paste
this
so on the left about
okay that's what we're starting with
h4
and a paragraph h4 is a heading
okay
and then i'm going to copy that button
again the button that we've used
in the header
okay so below below the paragraph i'm
going to put that button the button
container main button
okay i'm just reusing that button
i'm gonna save this
so there it is so we're reusing this
same button over and over again
i think that's good
okay so on the right side
uh right about
i'm gonna collapse this button
and then i'm gonna collapse this
paragraph
and then i'm gonna
be left with the right about so in here
i'm just gonna say
dot about
item
okay so the about item is gonna have a
class of dot
abt
text
okay so in here we're just gonna have a
p
p dot large
text
okay i'm gonna say maybe 650 or 560 plus
projects
okay
so here i'm just going to paste in
another paragraph the class of small
small text and then we're
going to the new run line beer it means
break break the line go to the new line
and then yeah we're just breaking
the text
okay so that's it for that
so
mainly on the right about we're just
going to have like a
a grid
okay so
i'm gonna go
independent components i'm gonna say
here
about
okay so in here i'm gonna say
about container
so in the about container i'm going to
do display
display
grid
then
grid template columns
i'll say repeat
and when i have two columns
uh two and then one fr they're all going
to have equal sizes
and then i'm gonna do padding top and
padding bottom of
i'm just going to paste in this so it's
a no-brainer painting top 3.5 putting
bottom fire frame
right about
okay so on the right about it's also
going to be a grid
okay display grid then grid
template columns so this one is going to
be to have the same thing
uh repeat two columns one fr
like that
and then uh below that we're going to do
grid gap so it's like spacing between
grid items
free gap we're going to do two ram so
that's like this spacing between two
items
okay
now let's save
let's go there
so that's the about item there it is
the right about item
we just need to keep starting
okay so we're gonna do dot about
item
i'm gonna give it a border one pixels
one pixel
and the border radius in the transform
and the shadow
the ones we've been using before
one pixel in the color of gray
okay so and however when we have this
when we have a i'm just gonna say cursor
to default
okay and then i'm going to say transform
translate
i want to translate y minus 50 minus the
minus 5 pixels
minus five pixels but i want to hover
and then it goes up so that's the kind
of effect i'm looking for and then the
border i'm going to change the border
color from primary to secondary
and then the box shadow i'm just going
to increase the intensity
the opacity
okay so from 0.1 to 0.32
okay i'm going to save this
go to the about section so there it is
so now we have a border surrounding when
we have a it turns green
okay so below that uh below the hover
we're going to
do the about
text
the word text okay so padding
padding
1.5 ram
now we're going to do this display flex
display to flex
and then uh we're also going to change
the direction
to column
all right so now we're going to look for
large
text
so the live text i'm just going to
change the font size to
3 ram
front weight
to 700
and then we're also going to change the
color
color to var
secondary
cylindry color
okay and then now we're going to target
this small text
but for this more text i'm just going to
have padding
left of three ram
three ram and then i'm going to do
position of relative
and then
text transform
text transform i'm going to do uppercase
so i want the text to be in uppercase
and then i'm going to do font size 1.2
ram
and then the color is going to be
gray and then late later spacing
letter spacing i want this to be two
pixels and then end
i'm going to give it a before so element
so it's going to be like a small line
okay with the position of absolute i'm
just going to paste in the code for that
so the content empty string percent of
absolute left zero
top
15 pixels width to ram high two pixels
i'm going to save this
okay so there it is so this is the
before suitable the leisure line here
i'm gonna inspect this
so there it is
okay so this is the grid where we have
two columns here
so we need uh three more objects here
first you have
like four items
so you can
clone these grid items here you can
about item you can clone this three more
times one two three
save and then just change the data to
whatever data fits you need
so there it is so now we have more items
for me to
change every item here i'm not gonna
do that i'm just going to paste in the
items that i've changed the data already
so i don't want to waste your time
changing the information about these
items
i'm just going to paste in all of the
items with data done to them already
okay so
they are
i've like sort of already filled in the
the data
so now let's go to the left side
okay so
this is the right about
and then we'll do dot left
about
so left about is just there isn't much
in there
so we're going to do
padding right
panning right it's going to be five ram
five ram
and then one target the p tag
line height
so the line knight for this p tag i'm
gonna set it to ramazo
and then i'm going to do padding top and
bottom it's going to be one ram
one ram and then uh the color it's going
to be gray one
okay so like that and then i'm going to
target the h4
is just putting into uppercase the text
the h4
and then the container of the button
actually i don't need to target the
content of the button just save
everything should
be nice
already
there it is so everything looks nice
be about
so now we just need to add more
more stuff below here so we have like
progress bars and the timeline stuff
so let's just do that
now
so let's go to the html
i'm going to collapse the
the about container i'm going to
collapse that so now i just want to
sort of
like
add
uh the stats
the
i'm gonna do about
stats
for stats okay
so in here um
in the bus stats nothing much nothing
much is going on here just in h4 saying
my skills
and then i'm gonna create
a class called
progress
progress
bars it's a div program
progress pass and then another div
called progress
bar
progress bar
okay so that's another class in there
we have a title called p
progress
title
okay so that's our p
progress title
i'm going to say html
five for this one
okay and then below that
uh we're gonna have dots progress
container
okay so in there uh we're going to
uh we're going to have like the progress
text
p dot
prog
prog text so this is the text uh
it's going to be like 80
or 90 it's up to you what whatever width
or whatever
percentage of your skill so in this case
i can i'll just say maybe 90 percent
uh that's like a p tag and then below
that i'm going to have a cluster of
progress so this is the actual progress
bar
and then in there it's gonna have a span
and then the class for this pattern is
gonna be html
okay so that's that for the
so this is the progress by item
we can duplicate this many times as many
depending on how many progress bars you
want to do
okay so now let's just go to the styles
so about container after that i'm just
going to say dot about
stats
about starts so here i'm just going to
do
padding bottom to four ram
because i want a bit of spacing
i'm gonna say progress
progress
bars
okay so i'm just gonna do a display grid
we've done that
two columns
and then below that i'm going to target
the
progress
bar
like that
here i'm just going to do display
flex flex direction
to column
okay i want them to be one after another
so that's why we're using the column
and then i'm gonna select the progress
title
prog
title
here i'm just going to give it you know
a text transform
text
transform to uppercase
so i'm going to put it into uppercase
font weight i'm going to put it to 500s
okay so after the progress title i'm
going to say
progress
progress container the progress con
class
display
flex
align items
to center
so in there we have a prop text as well
prog
text
so the prop text is gonna have a just a
gray color
okay now let's save and let's see what
we have so far
okay so there it is so i want next to
this text here to have a progress bar
okay
so
something is missing here
my skills
okay no no nothing is missing we just
need to stop this h4
okay so now
uh we just need to
let me check h4 start title
ah okay so we have a class will start
title for the h4 i'm gonna say
start
start
title
okay it's not there
okay we need to start that later
okay so now
uh we need to do the progress by now so
with the progress text after that we
have the progress
so the actual progress i'm going to say
width
width
100
so for this one height
it's going to be 0.45 ram
that's for the height
and then the background color
i'm going to put a position of relative
because
oops save this
all right
let's see what we got
so there it is so that's our progress
bar but we need something also inside to
show the progress the actual progress
okay so that's how we have that span
inside that uh inside the progress
so so the span is going to be
responsible
for filling in the width
so this span is going to have a position
of absolute that's why we did position
relative here so left and top is going
to be zero and then the height is going
to be 100
okay and then the background color is
going to be the secondary color the
green one
but if i set the width here
let's say maybe width
60 percent
as you can see it's there but if i want
to create more items here if i say
progress bar i'm going to say one two
three four five i'm gonna save
when i go
as you can see they all have the same
width i want them to have like different
width according to it maybe different
programming language or something
a different width
so to do that
we need to
give each
individual
progress bar
i'm gonna redo this undo
okay so you see this pan
it is a class of html so whatever
language you're doing give it a class of
that and then
after this pan
and then you target each individual
language and give it a different width
according to whatever data you want so
in this case it's 90 percent
okay
so now it's going to be
uh it didn't save because i didn't save
okay so now it's going to be 90 percent
as you can see it's 90 and then when i
do another programming language when i
copy the
progress bar so this is the actual
progress bar that i need to copy
multiple times i just need to change the
class names for the progress
span
okay so this file i just need to change
the class name and then put it to a
different width so in this case
i'm just going to
paste in the
the stats
that that's oops
i'm just going to paste in the
stats
okay so progress bars
so
there they are so now i've done the
progress pass off camera
so now we should have like six different
pro
program bars
okay there they are
but now there's something missing
look look this program progress bars
they have
different class names
okay so i'm just gonna copy those class
names here and give them different width
so here we've done the html already
i'm just gonna paste in html
css javascript
so make sure your width so i put it so
this one should be 90 percent
actually it's 80
for me i've put html to 80
and then the rest of the classes it's up
to you what you decide to do with them
so as you can see now we have different
now we have different progress bars so
it's only a matter of giving a
a different class name to
a different progress bar because we're
using a grid okay so each progress bar
you can give it a different class name
you can actually do as many progress
bars as many as you want it's you're not
limited to six because it's a grid right
so you can do as many as you want
as many as you want it's up to you
okay
so now
let's do this title here what did we
name this title
uh
i'm going to collapse the progress bars
so we see
what we're looking for
so the is called stats
so it's a it's actually starch starch
title
okay so
this chart title
i want this to be independent i wanted
to be outside of this
container i'm just going to go outside
i'm just going to
do that down here
i'm going to say text transform
to uppercase
then i'm going to give it a font size of
one point
for ram
and then text align
to center
and then i'm going to do
a padding
top and bottom is going to be
3.5 ram
3.5 left left and right is going to be
zero
and then position of relative
because i want to
create a before suit element inside it
so i'm gonna say before
so you know the drill before we've done
this before i'm gonna say content
set content to an empty string
and then left i'm just gonna set some
properties here left fifty percent
top zero percent
i'm gonna give it a background color of
gray
and then i'm gonna center this on the
x-axis so i'm gonna say transform
translate x and then minus 50
to center this on the x-axis
okay and now i'm going to go to the
okay so now we've titled my skill
okay
but we need a border actually i think we
need a border
so we can uh
give uh this title maybe a border a
border top or something
i don't know yeah let's do a border
i think that's that's the better way to
do it
actually not a border so this before
suit element is responsible for that
content
so we just need to give this a width
width is there position of absolute let
me expect to see why it's not showing
inspect
before suit element
it says it's there
transform translate x
left 50
i don't know why the
width height
pergola
oh i think this there's something wrong
with the background color
background
no it's not showing still
okay content empty string
person relative
i have no idea why it's not showing
save everything
again
i'm going to inspect
hmm
it's interesting
let me try to
redo the background color
still it's not working
i think i've done something wrong
somewhere
and before
so check your naming
start title
i'm just trying to figure out why the
let me see if i have this variable why
is it there
uh okay let's do something else uh i'll
figure it i'll figure out later what's
going on
why it's not working
so let's do something else so now we
need to
do the timeline
so i was i wanted to put like a line
here on top of the title but for some
reason
it's not showing
yeah i'll try to figure out why it's not
showing later on
uh let's
focus on the
so our bus stats i'm gonna collapse
so now we need to do the timeline
so for the timeline i'm just gonna
say dot
timeline
okay so for the timeline we're just
going it's it's going to be a grid as
well same same as
same stuff we've been doing
so it's going to be a grid and
we're going to have two columns of the
grid
so we're going to
have a timeline
timeline
item
okay so it's a grid item so timeline
item
so in the timeline yeah
timeline item i'm going to say dot
timeline
uh icon
so we're going to have an icon as well
and then the icon is going to be like a
briefcase icon
i'm going to put that you can go to
photosim and look for any icon that
you're looking for
and then
p dot tl
timeline
duration
and then here you can put like a
duration of
when you started working for a company
and stuff blah blah blah
and then we're just going to have an h5
with this pan inside
and then a paragraph with some random
the remove some text
okay that's it that's it for the
timeline item that's pretty much it
okay we just need to
uh add the title above the timeline
here
we can just say
my timeline
okay
so let's save
let's see what we got
so there it is so my timeline so we just
need to this is a timeline item
to do a grid for this timeline item
okay
so to do that uh we just need to
go to the
styles
main here i'm just gonna say
timeline
okay so dot timeline
i'm gonna say display grid uh two
columns we've been doing this so
i'm not gonna waste your time rewriting
and then i'm gonna say dot timeline
timeline
item
so for the timeline item i'm going to
say a personal relative because i'm
going to position absolutely icon
padding left
panning left is going to be three ram
left three ram and then a border of one
pixel border left so i'm going to give
it a border left of one pixel with the
color of gray five and then i'm gonna
target the tl
icon the individual iphone actual icon
i'm going to say percent of absolute
and then i'm going to say left
minus
27 pixels you can play around with this
value to find whatever value suits you
need okay i'm gonna save to show you
what i mean so i'm gonna i'm going to
inspect
so this is the
tl icon okay i haven't saved yet
okay so
tl icon
okay so now
so there is our icon okay so you can
sort of
play with this value the left left value
to see whatever you need
okay so the minus 27 was the
value that i found to
be better so i'm gonna say top
zero and then i'm going to say give it a
bacon color of secondary
and then i want it to be rounded so
width and height must be the same
for it to be rounded and then i bought a
radius of 50 to make sure it's rounded
okay so that's why i did width and
height that's the same so there it is so
we just want to center this icon using
flex
so display flex align items and justify
content to center to center the icon
okay so and then i just need to target
the icon itself and then give it a font
size
of 1.3 ram slightly bigger
okay
that's it the icon should be it should
be appearing nicely there it is
so now we just need to
uh
style this text and the title
okay so after here i'm just going to say
dot
tl
duration
duration
okay
so to your duration
i'm going to give it a padding and the
color
padding top and bottom is going to be
0.2 ram
left and right 0.6 ram and then
for the radius it's going to be 15
pixels
i want it to be rounded and then display
uh it's going to be inline
block
okay and then font size i want to be
smaller
font size is going to be 0.8 ram
and then we're going to do text
transform uppercase
uppercase and then we're just going to
change the font weight to 500 something
you know thicker
whoops
okay so now just save everything
so there's our timeline icon item i mean
okay so we just need to do the title in
the paragraph
so after the timeline duration
there is an h5
so the h5 is only mainly installing the
padding text transform in font size just
the standard stuff
okay and then i'm going to target this
pan inside the
and then i'm going to give it a color in
the front right in the front size it's
just the standard no more stuff
okay after after the h5 i'm gonna take
the paragraph i'm gonna give it a color
of gray
using our variable color
grade two
so that's the color for that gray number
two for the paragraph so i'm gonna
core again so there it is everything is
nicely styled so now we just need to
duplicate this multiple times and then
change the values so what you need to do
go back
and then go to the timeline item you
need to duplicate the actual timeline
item because
we've done this display grid on this
timeline two columns so we just need to
duplicate to put more grid items one two
three four five
and then you just need to change in the
data
to whatever suits you need
okay so in this case um i'm also going
to paste in some
some values again
because i don't want to
waste your time me changing these values
again and again so you can put it to
whatever values that you want
okay so
there it is so for me i've changed all
of the data i just made it random so for
it to look something you know somewhat
random
okay so for the line we'll come back and
do that later because i don't know
what's not showing
yeah i think i'll take a break for now
i'll see you in the next section
so now it's time to work on the
uh portfolios page
so this one is going to be super quick
and easy so it's just like a grid
um
so let's go to the portfolio
section
okay so in this section we're going to
uh
put some grid items so mainly you're
going to put the title we're reusing the
title that we've created already
and then just put change the name to my
portfolio just copy the title
from where we've done it before
and then
yeah put it there
so my portfolio put the title and then
when i go to the portfolio page you can
see the title of my portfolio
there it is
so now let's do the the content
so for the i'm going to have a paragraph
here
p
with the class of portfolio
text
just put some text in the paragraph
like uh random text
okay in this case i'm just going to put
some random text
so i'm going to say dot port
portfolio
folios
something like that and then here i'm
going to say dot portfolio
item
so in portfolio item we're going to
have
uh an image
dot image
and then img
image portfolio one
so we have portfolio all the way to
seven the images
and then
uh below that um we're going to have
below the image we're going to have dot
hover
items so when i have the portfolio item
i want to display the links
where you can
download the project if you want if a
user wants to
okay so i'm gonna
have an h3 in there
i'm gonna say
project
source
so the source of the project like the
source code or something
maybe your guitar blinks
okay below that i'm going to have a
class with icons
of icons
so here i'm going to have an anchor tag
a link so each
link is going to lead to whatever
website you want to so for example if i
say www.google.com
and then i'm going to say
target
target i'm going to put the target to
blank so it means open a new page
so if the target is goes to blank it's
going to open a new page
and then in there i'm just going to add
an icon
okay so
you can put as many icons as you want so
in this case i'm going to do github
i want to do github youtube
okay github youtube and uh
github youtube
uh
that's the icons i'm going to be using
so now we have one grid item so we need
like
six grid items or more whatever it
depends it's up to you
so we're going to have like a grid with
three columns because you want to have
three grid uh three grid items per row
okay so let's go to the styles
i'm going to say
port folios
so that that's that's marking my
way i'm going to start doing the
portfolio so i'm going to say dot
portfolio text
port
text portfolio text
i'm gonna give it a padding
panning top and bottom is gonna be
to ram left and right zero and then text
align
text align it's gonna be the center
and then after that i'm going to target
the portfolios
folios the container and then i'm going
to do a display grid
we've been doing this for
ages grid template columns
and then we're going to do repeat and
then we're going to have three and one
fr
okay so we're going to have three
columns and then grid gap spacing
between grid items
so it's going to be two ram as usual
and then i'm going to target the
margin top i'm going to give it a margin
top
of three ram and then i want to do
dot pot
folio
item the actual individual item
but for the item i'm going to do poisson
of relative
and then i'm going to target the image
inside
inside the portfolio item i'm going to
give it a width
of 100
okay and height
of 300 pixels
and then i'm going to do object fit
to cover
and then
border radius
but the radius is going to be 15 pixels
15 pixels okay
and then below that below the image i'm
going to say dot hover
items
hover
items
okay so with
actually before i do that i'll just save
save save save
okay so there it is so it looks looking
nice
so it's looking nice
so the image
we just need to keep going uh the water
radius for some reason
didn't apply
uh border radius 15 pixels
uh we also need to put i think we need
to put this also on the
item itself
i believe nope it's not working let me
inspect this
but the radius
it doesn't seem to be working
what are a
border
oh
border radius
okay we'll fix it later
so now on they have items
portfolio item let me just double check
the class name
so make sure the class names
okay that's that's okay
have items width
100
height 100
the background color is going to be the
primary and then position is going to be
absolute
so when we have a
okay so it's not showing yet
okay
uh border radius 50 percent is all
border radius
15 pixels
okay so they have items position
relative
let me just have a check
inspect
oh it's have items
have
i
where is it
like that
okay so there is our other item that's
this this is this green color
here so we're going to center all of
this content here on the center
so you already know how to do this we're
going to use flex
flex align items to center and
flex direction to column
okay like so
and then
let's see what we got
it's loading
it's compiling the styles sometimes it
does this
okay so there is all of the items are
aligned so now we just need to style the
individual icons
okay
so to do that i'm going to start with an
h3
the h3 the heading
inside the
inside there i'm just going to increase
the font size and give it a color in the
margin
so the front side is going to be 1.5 ram
and the margin bottom of 1.5 ram
okay and then i'm after that after the
h3 i'm gonna target the
icons
i'm gonna say
i'm gonna i'm going to align the items
as well display flex
to center
and then the icon individual icon i want
to give it a background color
of the primary so width and height has
to be same for us to be to round to make
sure it's rounded but the radius 50
width and height must be the same so
whatever width and height you put make
sure it's the same for us to make sure
the
icons are nicely rounded
so for example like this the icons
around it so we just need to
center this in the middle with flex
okay so you already know how to do that
and then we're going to give it a margin
left and right for us to space them
and then cursor is going to be pointer
and then we're going to do a transform
transition i mean transition
that's it for that
okay so
there it is
so on however we might want to
actually i want to change the font size
of this icon these icons so i'm going to
target the
eye
so you can insert the icon i'm going to
check the eye change the font size and
the color to white and then give it a
margin
left and right
of one
like so
okay so when we have this icon
i'm going to say end
hover
what do we want to happen
whatever i just want to change the
background color
of the icon and the
actual
icon i tag okay so it's just changing
the color
so let's see
okay so now it's changing the color
so i don't want to display this by
default okay
i want to only display this when i have
this grid item
so in here i'm going to get rid of the
to get rid of it so to get rid of it i'm
going to
uh say
i'm going to
say
uh go up up the h3
i'm going to give opacity of zero
opacity zero it means i'm
like hiding but still there i'm minding
the visibility opacity of zero
and then i'm also going to do scale zero
transform
transform scale
zero
okay
and then uh let's do also a transition
the one we've been using
okay so um i want to
one have a a grid item
i want to return this to different
values
opacity and the scale
okay so to do that
i'm just gonna
scroll down
i'm just gonna say
up here outside i'm just going to say
portfolio
portfolio item
okay and hover
so when i have the portfolio item is the
grid item and then i'm going to say dot
have items on them too
opacity i'm going to set that to one
scale
also to one
okay
so let's see what we got
okay so when i have a it's
showing but i just need to fix this
image thing the image problem i don't
know why it's not working for the
let me just inspect the image
image
width
100
uh height
300 pixels
okay so that's the parent of the image
and then the image itself
i'm gonna set the image itself height
to 100 percent
hmm
something fishy is going on
if you don't set the height
object fit oh it's contained it's
supposed to be cover
it's my fault
yeah
myself for contain
contain
object fit is supposed to be cover
so it's going to cover the whole grid
item
all right so now it's covering the whole
grid item
so x everything works as expected so now
um what we need to do is just duplicate
these
portfolio items
okay
we can duplicate them by
you can also actually you know animate
the
the rotate but i'm not going to do that
in this video so let's go to the html
so we've we've done display
grid we're displaying three
three columns
so
what i'm going to do now is i'm just
going to duplicate and change the values
so we have the portfolio images
so the image you can change from
portfolio one to two three four four
five or you can use your own images if
you want so you just you just need to
change around the values
okay so portfolio item
i'm gonna collapse portfolio item
and then i'm just going to duplicate
this multiple times one two three four
as many as many times as you want
save and then go back we should
hopefully should have more portfolios
and then you just need to change around
these images as well
okay
so yeah i'll
leave the rest up to you
portfolio item
okay i'm just undoing this
portfolios
okay so i've pasted in
the with the data change so i've changed
all of the images
so you just need to do the same as you
just need to change to your own images
of your liking so i've changed the
images
so now yeah let's move to the next
section if you remember this uh
before suit element was not showing
it's because i forgot to do something
i'm going to expect
i forgot to
do position of absolute
on the proposal element so you make sure
you do position
absolute and then it will show somewhere
down
there it is so
go to the stat
start title
title and then the content in here
to position of absolute
so hopefully now the line should show
so now you should have a line there it
is a line here
okay
so that's it for the portfolios now
let's go for the blogs the blogs is kind
of
uh similar to the
portfolios because it's it's a grid as
well it's going to be f it's going to
have uh it's going to have three
three columns
okay
so we just need to also
go to the blogs
portfolios i'm going to collapse this
i'm going to go to the blogs
i'm going to say dot
blogs
content
content that's like the parent the main
parent container so in there i'm going
to paste in the title
and then the title just change it to my
blog so we've created this title before
so it's inside the header that's where
actually it's inside the
uh the about section that's where we
first created this title here so just
copy the name main title we've solved
this we've styled this title already so
you just need to change the text
okay so hopefully we should have main
title in the blog section there it is
my blogs
okay so with the main title
so it's like the blog section
so now uh after the title i'm just going
to do dot blogs
so in the blogs
i'm going to
do the blogs that's where i'm going to
do all of the blogs
so in the blogs i'm going to do
dot not do to a blog
each individual blog so it's not
the blog is a grid item i wanted to be
duplicating this multiple times to
create multiple grid items
okay
so the blog i'm going to have an
image uh img
i'm gonna say blog one
okay so you can set whatever image you
want to use
so after that i'm gonna
do dot blog
text
and then in there i'm going to have an
h4
uh you can put whatever text you desire
but anything that you want and then
after that we're going to have a
paragraph with random text as well
like that
okay that's it for the blog item we just
need to style this
there isn't much to it
we just need to start this and then we
can go to the next section
okay so uh we just need to go to the
styles and get started with the blogs
so after
portfolios
portfolios and then here we just want to
do
blogs section
okay so here
we can do dot
blogs
so the blog is going to be a grid
display
so that's the parent of each individual
blog
grid so in here we're just going to have
three columns
so the standard stuff we've been doing
before
and then each individual blog
we're going to have a position of
relative
and then background color is going to be
gray five
and we're going to give it about a
radius of five pixels to make the
corners
uh be rounded you know
and then we're going to give it a box
shadow
you can use the variable or you can use
this one
so one pixel one pixel one pixel one the
y one pixel on the x and then 20 pixels
for the player
okay and then when we have this blog
item
what do we want to happen
so when we have a uh i want the image to
sort of pop out of the
block container
i'm actually also going to increase the
box shadow
i'll copy this box shadow
paste
and then i'm just going to increase like
the opacity of the box shadow from 0.1
to 0.3
and then after that i'm also going to
transform this
and then translate why
i wanted the block to go up slightly a
little bit so minus 50
pixels i wanted to go up minus 55 pixels
and then i'm going to apply the
transition as well the one we've been
using
and then inside inside that one we have
a
i'm also going to target the image so
the image filter
filter
i'm going to do grayscale
i'm going to do zero
okay and then i want to do transform
translate
actually scale we're going to scale the
image
i want it to be larger
so 1 by 1.1 so the image the normal
scale is one so i want it to be slightly
larger by
0.1 okay so it's like
10 larger by 10 percent i don't know
yeah 10 percent
okay so and then we're also going to do
a box shadow
yeah we're going to do a backside of the
image
so the
mini box shadow is on the y axis which
is four pixels so we want it to show a
lot of
shadow
uh on the y-axis okay
so now uh let's save let's see what we
got so far
i'm gonna go to the blog section
oh it seems like there's a glitch
somewhere
yep there is a glitch
i don't know what happened
vlogs
let me refresh this i don't know why
it's glitching
okay
vlogs
that's
that's odd let me double check the class
names
blogs
blog item
oops plugs content
i don't know what's going on okay i
think
i know what's going on
uh go back
check the classes id
so the id blogs
class oh
this class name
is matching
our blog class name
so get rid of this class name we're not
going to use it so get rid of that
i don't know why this this class name
didn't affect that
portfolio
i think you can get rid of these class
names we're not gonna use them
let's see if it's gonna affect anything
let's save
yep nothing affected
yep nothing affected here
okay
yeah so we didn't use those class names
up here so just get rid of them i think
we're using this about class name so
leave that for now if it's affecting it
if it's affecting something it means
we're using the class just get rid of it
okay
so now
no glitches
so there it is so the image sort of like
pops out of the grid item it's like boom
boom
but we need to make it transition nicely
smoothly
so to do that yeah let's go back to
these styles
so after they have effect
after we've finished with the harvard we
need to now style the image outside of
the hover
so i'm going to do image with
100
and then i'm going to do
height 300 pixels
and then i'm going to do object fit
object fit to cover
to cover and then
i'm going to do i'm going to give it
like corners
uh on the top
top right and top left i'm gonna say
border
radius top
top
uh
border radius
top
radius
by the radius top
top left
so top left is going to be uh so for the
top left just give it like five pixels
and then we're going to do top right
five pixels or so
so let's save let's see what we have
uh so there it is so if you bought the
top top right and left so
there it is
okay so now we just need to style the to
give it a transition
and uh give the
and the filter
so when we have the filter
uh
we need to affect the filter now
actually so future 100 so here we set
that filter to
grayscale 0 and then here it's like 100
and then a transition to make it slow to
transition slowly
oops
okay so it's going to transition slowly
it's it's gray scale
okay when we hover
is going to go to 100 uh to go to zero
so by default the grayscale is 100
when we have that the gray scale is
going to go to zero which is the you
know black and white
okay so the image sort of like pops out
okay so after the image
i'm gonna do dot
blog
text
so for the block text
i'm going to give it a margin
margin top
actually margin top so for the margin
top i'm going to do minus seven pixels
so you can play around with this value
you can
try to find any value that you see fit
but for this one i'm i've found like
seven pixels minus seven pixels
to be a good value
and then i'm gonna do a padding top and
bottom it's going to be
1.1 ram
actually padding on the top and bottom
around everything so
i want to block text every padding
around of 1.1 ram let me show you what i
mean
so as you can see here there's like
spacing around the text so that's the in
1.1 ram
okay
so that's that so now let's uh i'm just
going to do
a border
a butter top
okay
so i'm going to do butter top like this
at pixels
okay so that's the border
so when i hover the water gets covered
that's that's the effect we're looking
for and then there's like a nice shadow
okay
it seems like when i have the shadow on
the x-axis is too much i might want to
get rid of that
box shadow
x
y four pixels so on the x i'm gonna set
to a zero on the x-axis i don't want
anything on the x
okay since you didn't make any
live changes but you can always reduce
the blur
maybe to 15
okay so
you can reduce the blur to 15 yeah i
think it looks good
so now uh let's style the the text
okay so now in the black uh blocks text
i'm going to target the h4
i'm just going to change the font
and the color
so the font
and then when we have her
when we have her
i'm going to set the color to green
so it's just uh color
color secondary
okay like that and then the after the h4
i'm gonna take the paragraph
i'm just gonna set the color as well
color to gray
gray too and then give the line height
so the spacing of the lines
to ram
and then we're also going to do padding
bottom
of one
ramp so just to give it a bit of spacing
so now let's save
okay so that's our blog item it's fully
styled so what we all we need to do now
is just to
populate the blog items okay
so to do that we've been doing this uh
forever so we just need to get this grid
item and populate this multiple times
to
whatever amount of blogs that you're
looking for
in this case i'm just going to popular
multiple times and change the values
and the images to whatever values that
suits your need so just populate this
multiple times
and change around the values
okay
and then i'm just gonna put like my own
values
i don't waste your time doing this on
screen
so
i've done that now
there it is so now i have different
content for the blogs items
okay
yeah that's it for the blog items now
let's move on to the contacts
so the contact section we're going to
have two sections left and right
because we're going to do some inputs
okay
so for the contact section go down here
and then um we're going to do the title
as well we're going to put a title
as usual but first i'm going to do dot
contact
container
and then i'm going to paste in the title
so the title is going to be contact
uh
if you still don't know we did we did
this title from the beginning in the
header so we're just reusing that title
component over and over
changing the values
okay so and then i'm going to do dots
contact
contact content
container
contact content container
okay so we're going to have just left
contact and then we're going to have
left and right contact
left and right contacts oh left
this one is right
contact
okay
so
let's uh start with the left contact
okay so with the left contacts
uh we're going to have an h4
and a paragraph first
so h4 in the paragraph
so the h4
says contact me here and the paragraph
just a random paragraph
okay and then below that we're going to
have like another div
code dot
contacts
info
so in the contact info it's going to
have some icons
a lot of icons for for the contact info
okay so here i'm just going to say
dot
contacts
item
okay
and then in there we're going to have an
icon dot icon
in the contact item
and then we're going to have
an actual ite
so in here i need a location icon
and then below the location i am going
to say location
okay i'm going to save let's see what we
have
so when i go it says location see
there's a location item here icon
um
there's a location item icon i mean
before the location text okay so i want
to have multiple icons and text
next to it
okay so to do that we just need to
duplicate the contact item multiple
times
and change around the icons okay
so in this case
actually after the
icon
i'm gonna
do a paragraph
i'm gonna say
london
united
kingdom
okay so we're still in the contact item
so we just need to duplicate the contact
item multiple times
okay for us to have
multiple multiple items
okay so i'm just going to paste in some
contact items
i don't waste your time doing these
contact items on screen
so contact item paste that in multiple
times change the con uh the icons
and change the information
to whatever you want
so there it is so these are the
icons that i'm using
okay so
we've done that so now let's do start
doing the styles
i'm gonna say
contact contact section
okay so
let's start doing the contact so for the
contact
we're going to do display flex
dot
contact
content
container
okay so we're gonna do display flex we
want everything to be next to each other
and then padding top
3.5 ram
3.5
ram
okay and then
first we're going to target the
left content
so that's left
contact actually
contact
so for the left contact i'm gonna do
flex
to i want it to be smaller than the
right one so the right one i'm gonna set
that flex to one to make it cover the
remaining space
so now this is it's actually not smaller
it's because i haven't put content on
the other one so that's why it looks
weird at the moment
okay
so you know what let me put the content
first so for us to see
how things are progressing let me put
all of the content
all of the content that we need
okay so below the
contact item here
after so after the
contact info after the conduct info
i'm going to put another div so this one
is going to be contact
contact
contact
i
cons
so we want to have like some
icons that are gonna lead to social to
social media
okay
so in here i'm gonna say
dot
contact
icon
so this one is contact icons
and then this one is contact icon
okay like that and then i'm going to do
an anchor tag that's going to lead us to
whatever
platform
wwe dot
facebook
facebook.com
oh it depends wherever you want to go to
just put a link there
okay and then here i'm just gonna
paste in a facebook link
and then make sure you put the target to
blank if you want to open that to a new
tab
target
to blank
okay so that's the icon for facebook
i'm gonna paste in the rest of the items
okay so we have twitter and stuff
okay that's it for the left side so we
just need to go to the right side so the
right side is going to have like a form
i'm going to say form
[Music]
dot contact
contact form
form like that
okay so in here we're just going to have
some inputs
i'm going to have a div called input
control dot input
control
okay like that and then we're going to
have two inputs the first one is input
text
and then we're going to it's going to be
required
required and then placeholder
to
a placeholder is going to be like
your name
okay so we're also going to do another
input
you know what we can just duplicate the
one that we have
and the other one is going to be email
your email
okay like so so now we just need to
duplicate this input control one more
time
actually not one more time uh
here i'm gonna get rid of email
here i'm just gonna say
enter
type subject i don't know enter subject
subject
like that
and then
um
i'm just going to also do input control
and then this one is going to be text
area
text area
and then you can leave the name blank if
you want and then
the columns i'm going to do 15
and then eight rows
like so
okay
so
that's pretty much it uh we just need
the button the button that we've created
before i'm gonna put in a
i'm gonna put in in a class
code
dot
submit
btn
i'm just gonna paste in the button that
we've created before
so it's called main button we've done
that created that button before we've
used it multiple times
i'm just going to save this to see what
we have
22
okay so
there we go that's what we got
so now we just need to
get started with styling this stuff
so go to the styles
okay so
left contact uh
we're gonna do dots
right
contact
okay so right contact and then um for
the right i'm gonna say flex
three so this one flex two and then this
one is flux three
so there you go so this is occupying
more space
okay
flux three
and then margin
left is gonna be something like maybe
three ram
okay and then below that i'm gonna do it
dot input
control
control
the input controller class
okay i'm going to do margin for that
margin top and bottom is going to be one
point
five ram left and right zero and then
i'm gonna target the inputs inside there
okay
i'm gonna do border radius
30 pixels and then i'm gonna do font
weight
front weight inherit
one size
in
here it's
uh fun family
inherit
okay and then i'm gonna do a padding
top and bottom is gonna be point eight
ram
left and right is going to be 1.1 ram
you can change these values to put
values that you want
outline is going to be none
border
i'm going to give it to none as well
but if none and then we just need to do
a background color in the width
of 100 background color and color of
white
and then resize
want it to be none because we don't want
the
form and the text area to be resized so
i'm gonna put a comma and then text
area as well on the text area to uh have
these styles as well i'm gonna save
save everything
let's see what we have so there it is
okay
but
i want this your name and your email to
be next to each other
okay
so i want this to be next to each other
so to do that
i am going to give the input control
this one
another class called input
control
actually i'll just do like this input
control too
okay so input control to after the input
control
uh that's where i'm going to style that
i'm going to do display
flex
okay and then i'm gonna say
last child
the last input
the last input i'm going to give it a
margin left
margin left of 1.5 from
the last child
okay let's go and see what we got there
it is so last child this one it's gonna
have a margin left of 1.5 so everything
looks equal like this
okay
so we can actually increase this font
weight of this text to maybe something
like 500 to make it more thicker or you
can leave it like this it's up to you
what you want
okay
you can also
text area you can say
placeholder
message
here like this
and then you can have like a nice
placeholder everywhere if you want like
this you can do a message here like that
okay so that's that
now uh
the button
we just need to
you know center the button
so to do the button
yeah after the
uh after that after the
input control you can do dot
submit
btn
so it's just display flex
display flex
uh just for content
flex start
okay so let's go back
there it is so our button is showing
nicely
so now we just need to
do the left side
all right
so let's uh go ahead and do the left
side
which is just uh styling the text and
everything so the left side what do we
got
there's some contact items
okay so we're doing flex 2 for the left
and then
i'm going to target the h4
so for the h4 margin top
i'm going to do one ram
font size
to ram
and then i'm going to do
text transform
transform to uppercase
okay after that i'm going to target the
paragraph
i'm going to give it imagine top and
bottom one ram line line height of 2 ram
we've been redoing this we should have
done that into a global
global style but it's okay let's keep
going
i will do contacts
info
so in the contact info we have a contact
item
dot contact
item if you remember the class names so
we just want to
do display
flex
um we're doing align items to center
justify content space between
displacement
space between let's see what we have
so there it is the spacing between
so now
uh we just need to
target the paragraph inside the contact
item
i'm going to do p
margin
margin top and bottom is 1.3 ram
and then zero left and right and then
we're going to override the existing one
which using the important
okay and then we're going to do padding
top and bottom
padding top and bottom is going to be
zero and then left and right
actually padding everything
just padding around everything we want
to reset it to zero
and then we are overriding with the
important keyword
okay so now everything we have a point
three margin top and bottom
okay for each item so there's like a
margin top 3.3 ram
everything looks nice now we just need
to start the icons
okay
so
after the paragraph i'm gonna say
dot icon
okay so for the icon i'm gonna say i'm
gonna put them in a grid
display grid
display grid and then grid template
columns i'm gonna
so i'm putting it in a grid because i
want
restart this
oh okay it's not showing why because
i've used the grid already so i'm just
gonna
show you why grid template columns
i'm gonna say 40 pixels
for the first column and then one fr for
the second column which is where the
text is for the pixels for the icon
okay
and then i'm gonna go back
so the reason i did a grid is because i
wanted this this text items
to be in line with one another so if
it's a grid it's going to make sure
they're aligned so i want to inspect
this
so as you can see
this one is a grid item
okay so
each grid item
each item is going to have
the first column of the grid is going to
be 40 pixels no matter what of these
grid items each one is going to have
like column the first one of 40 pixels
so the hands they're going to have equal
spaces and they're going to leave
they're going to be on the same line
like that
so you get the idea and then icon i'm
going to target the i the icon inside
there i'm going to say display
flex
and then align items
center
and then i'm going to do font size the
front size i'm going to change that to
something like 1.3 ram
okay so
uh there it is so now the icons are much
bigger so now we just need to do the
these icons here and then we're done for
the contact page
okay so write content uh
contact
contact info
so contact info
after the contact info
uh we need to do the
uh contact icon dot contact
icon
so if you forgot to know what that is is
the
uh contact icon where is it where is it
where is it somewhere down here
so it's this this container here contact
icon container here so that's what we're
doing now
okay so now we're doing this container
uh contact icon
so we're going to do display
flex
display flex and then i'm going to do
margin
top so for margin top is going to be
sort of like 2 ram
and then we're going to target the
anchor tag in there
which is going to take us to external
websites
uh we're just gonna do display flex and
give it a color
and center everything
we've been doing that with flex
and then to make sure it's rounded we've
been doing this width and height
must be the same
and border border radius to 50
okay so
my i'm gonna do margin top and bottom
zero top and bottom
point four ram left and right
okay
and then we can do the transition the
one we've been doing
okay and then
on half a
when we hover this
uh we just want to change the background
color
and also for the icon as well we just
want to change the color to the primary
color
okay
and then after the hover just in general
not in the over we want to start the eye
icon we're going to do display
flex
align items
center
justify content center
font size
1.3 ram
all right
so now
there it is so now we have a nice have
animation
uh
yeah that's uh this concludes our
our website now we just need to work on
the dark theme light and dark mode
and then we're done
okay so now i'm just gonna go to the
html
and i'm just gonna put like an uh
after the controls i'm gonna do dot
i'm gonna say
theme
btn
here i'm just gonna put like an
icon for the
to toggle the dark mode light and dark
mode
okay so team btn
so i just need to style that and then
we're done uh we just need to start the
theme btn
okay
so
ctrl
okay so after the controls i'm gonna do
dodge team btn
so here i'm gonna do padding
i wanna ram
and then cursor to pointer
and then the background
width and height must be the same for us
to make them rounded
so i want the button to be rounded
okay
like that and then uh display uh flex
want to send everything with flex so you
know that what's that that is already
and then imagine
top and bottom is going to be
0.7 ram and then 0 left and right
i'm also going to paste in the box
shadow you can put this into a variable
so you don't have to do this
and then i'm going to target the eye
it's only changing the font size and the
color and setting the point events to
none so we don't click it
okay so
yeah i mean
you know what
i've been
let's see what we have oh it doesn't
exist because i've been copying the
wrong styles
sorry it's my it's my fault i've been uh
looking at the wrong element
i'm gonna do
top
five percent
uh right
three percent
and then i'm gonna do
width
70 pixels
same as the height
so we want to make sure this is rounded
height
okay and then i'm going to do border
radius 50
so it's going to be rounded and then i'm
going to set the background color
and give it a position of fixed
and then center the center with flex
okay
like that
so case a pointer position of fixed so
now it's going to be here at the top
right
okay so we want to give it a box shadow
as well
like what we did in the text transform
okay
so
there it is so i'm going to do when
active
so when i click what do i want to happen
when i click the button so i'm going to
do transform
and then i'm going to translate on the y
so i'm going to do like minus 5 x 55
pixels
and then the is
it should be 0.1 second make sure it's
very low
not high
so for if you put the value too high you
will not see the effect so for example
let's let me say 0.5 0.6 pixels
no 6 pixels seconds
0.6 seconds
when i click you won't see the effect
but when i hold it takes like points it
takes a lot of time to
do the effect you have to hold but i
want the effect to be that quick when i
click
so that's why i'm using point one second
to make sure like you can see
the effect on click so when i click as
you can see like the button is like
moving
or you can reduce this width uh not the
width i mean
the height of translation
to minor three so when you click it's
like you know
translating
okay so that's that so now we just need
to do the icon
so the icon is just changing the font
size and the color
and setting the point defense to none
okay so there it is
so now we just need to work on the
toggle
so it's going to be really quick we just
need to
go to javascript
to javascript after the
sections active
we can say
toggle theme
toggle
theme
and then here we're going to say cons
theme btn is going to document
document
dot query selector
the query selector
and then here we're going to do dot
theme btn
that's the class name we've given to
so here i want to say theme button i'm
going to add an event listener
uh add event listener
and then it's gonna
listen for a click
and then it's gonna take in a callback
function
don't worry we can do another function
now because we're not using this keyword
then i'm gonna say let
element
and then i'm going to say
document the element is going to be
documented body the body
okay
document of body
and then here i'm just going to toggle
the class element which is the body
dot class list
dot toggle
on click okay
so we're just toggling one click i'm
just gonna put a class called light
mode
okay so when i click that it's going to
toggle this class on and off on and off
on and off so now let me save
so let me inspect this so let's watch
out for the body element
so body here so we we were like
selecting the word element in the
javascript so now when i click this
it's toggling the class
light
it's adding the class and removing the
class adding and removing the class
okay so now we just need to
uh set the light mode class
so for the light mode
um
i'm gonna go all the way up
i'm gonna here
i'm gonna do light
mode that's the class name we're talking
i'm gonna copy all of these colors here
okay and then i'm gonna paste them down
here
okay
so
uh for the for the light mode
you just need to exchange the colors
you've used for example
uh for the background
i've used the
uh
this dark color here so don't change the
variable name just need to change the
property
so
i'm going to change it from the black
color
oops
to the
white color
okay
like that and then save
then when i click the background is
going to change to white okay so it's on
this light mode class
okay
so you just need to change the values of
the variables to different
stuff just mix them around
okay so for me
i'm using white as the main background
and then for the secondary i'm using a
different color which is like sort of a
pink color
okay for the secondary so when i toggle
the light
it's going to change to this one
pink color
okay every secondary color is going to
change this pink color
okay so
let's keep going
i need also
need to change
the text color which is white
so for white i think i'm using some
gray number
white i'm going to paste this
uh
for white i'm actually using gray four
so gray four
that's where you're gonna put white okay
so this is gray for now
so it's just the variable name is still
being used
but you just need to change the value of
it
okay
uh let me see if we need to change
anything else
okay so let me go to other components
okay so
yeah we might need to change some colors
you know instead of me going this uh
changing the colors one by one
i'm just gonna copy
paste the colors that i found worked for
me
you can change these colors to whatever
you want so you just need to mix them
around
don't change the variable name because
we've been using these variables for a
reason so we just need to change the
value of the variable on a different
color mode
okay
so in this case
so what works for me is this color uh
color scheme
i think it really works for me very well
you can you know use a different
color scheme that you want it's really
up to you
but this one is really perfect for me
okay everything works fine
yeah i mean this project is not
responsive uh i don't have time to make
it responsive
uh this is the only time i had to make
the video but i it depends how many
people have requested in the comments
if you want me to if you want to see me
doing the responsive stuff you can
let me know in the comments and then now
consider making a video about it we'll
see how many people have requested
yeah if you have any questions or
anything
don't forget to
ask me in the comments or you can
send me an email
yeah that's it
please don't forget to like subscribe if
you're new i'll see you on the next one
okay so now let's work on the media
queries uh let's try to make this
website responsive
as you can see where we left off the
website is not responsive at all
okay so we just want to try to make it
adapt to whatever width we're using
i'm actually using a different project
but everything is going to be the same
everything is the same the class is
everything is the same it's just a
different folder name
okay so now let's
go into the styles and create a new
style and put it's going to be a sas
partial to create a partial we need to
use in underscore and then we're going
to say media
and then dot scss
so this is uh this file is going to be
responsible for the media queries
so um
i've already kind of of looked off
screen work where i'm i need to do some
breakpoints
but if i haven't done that you're gonna
have to like find breakpoints which your
website your website is gonna start
breaking
so i'm going to start with a smaller
screen i'm going to start with 600
pixels
so i'm going to do a media
and media screen
screen
oops
screen and then end
and then i want to say max width
max width
max so the max width for this one we're
going to put that to 600 pixels
okay so
make sure this spacing here is correct
so if you do like this it's not going to
work so you the spacing must be correct
the same as i've done it so make sure
everything is correct
okay so i'm going to start with the
header let's see in the header
so it's 600 pixels
it's 600
so this is the size uh it's 600 i want
to have zero padding okay so as you can
see there's a lot of padding
if i check to the in the styles
it should be padding somewhere
so this padding right here i'm gonna set
that to zero
okay so there should be
yeah so i'm gonna set every every
padding here to zero
so i'm going to say header
i'm going to set padding
to zero
okay
so uh also the other thing is for us to
use these media queries we need to
import this file
so let's go up to import a partial
we just do it import
and then we're going to say
media
okay so you don't need to include the
file extension because sas already knows
knows what it is it's a it's a sas
partial so you don't need to include the
extension here
as i save
and i'm going to refresh nothing works
because for me the queries to work they
must always always always be at the
bottom of everything they must be
down here after everything because
everything is executed line by line
so the media queries must be at the
bottom like this and then you have to
import them here down here instead of up
top
okay so now save
and save the
media and uh yeah let's see if the
middle the middle curve is working for
the header click the header
let's see so the middle color is there
so now the pattern is set to zero
for the header
it's actually the right header the right
header content that we need to also
set the padding to zero i believe
this one right header
padding
right we actually need to set that to
zero
okay so we're going to say
header
target header
uh header and then dot right
header
and then i'm going to say padding 0 to
that
okay so right header
filing 0
some something is weird is going on
apparently zero
oh
there's still padding right actually we
need to override everything so he's
important so only use this important one
is really important one you have to so
now we've overridden every every all of
the styles all of the paddings
okay
so actually
uh we might want to set this to two ram
maybe just give it a little bit of
padding
around yeah let's set that to 2 ram
okay so we also want to get rid of these
controls here
so to do that
we can just say
dot controls
that's the class name so if you want to
double check the selector inspect the
controls
and find the class name there it is
controls
okay so for the controls i'm going to
say top i'm going to set that to auto
to auto and then
we're going to say bottom we're going to
say bottom 0
i want it be to be at the bottom and
then flex direction
is going to be around now to the default
or initial you can say initial
and then we're going to say justify
content
and then i'm going to center that
and then we're going to say left
we're going to give it 50
because we want it to be centered
and then we're going to transfer
transform and translate x
transform and translate x
minus 50
only on the x axis so translate x
safe let's see what we got
so there they are the controls are down
here
and uh yeah in there uh we actually we
also need to set the width to 100
and then
we might also want to give it a
background color to distinguish it be
like with our content
and then var we're going to use gray
five
gray five that's background color
and then we're also going to do
control the individual control
so the individual control we're going to
give it a margin
one ram top and bottom and then 0.3 ram
left and right
so
uh now there they are the controls are
down here instead of up so when i go
over the width it's not there anymore so
now they're there
okay
so now the controls are where we want
them to be
i'm also going to
keep styling the header
actually i need to decrease the theme
button with azure
i'm going to say
dot
theme
vtn
so we're going to
decrease the width to 50 pixels
and the height to 50 pixels as well
okay so width and height 50 pixels
okay so now let's see let me just double
check from recording yep okay so as you
can see now it's smaller
on a smaller device
okay so
uh we also want to target the header
content
header content
add the content if you don't know what
it is i'm going to inspect again to show
you the hello content inspect so this is
the other content it's a grid as you can
see i'm going to target that
so the header content uh we're going to
change the grid so we're going to just
go and say grid
template columns i'm just going to say
one file one fr going to have
uh two columns actually no no one for
just one fr because we just want to have
one column instead of two now so just
one fr so now we have one column
okay so but uh it's still a bit messy
uh we say playing bottom
six ram
okay
so yeah so and also i want maybe i might
want the text actually to be at the top
to do that we just need to you know
change these grid items
change them swap them around
so let's let's keep going
so now
i'm going to target the left header i'm
going to say left
header
i'm going to target that
i'm going to say
the dot h shape i'm going to get rid of
that green shape
and then i'm going to i'm going to set
that to display to none
so i don't want it anymore so as you can
see it's gone now
so after the left header let's go to the
right header
so the right header
okay so for the right header i'm going
to
start
i want the right header
to be at the top okay so how do we do
that so we just need to change the grid
so we say grid draw it's a grid item so
i want it to be the starting point to be
one so i'll show you what that means so
when i inspect
uh where's the grid
so this is the grid right so
it starts at one it goes two so i want i
want this row it was a two to be at one
to be the first row
okay
so uh we just want to also
i'm going to s
set the width width
uh width i'll set it to 90 maybe
90
okay and then i'm going to set margin 0
auto to center margin
0 and auto just to center the content
okay now inspect
okay
so everything looks good
all right so now let's uh let's keep
going
i'm also want to target the name
actually
the name
font size
i'm just going to change that to 2.5
2.5
ram
[Music]
okay
so ram
and then save let's see
is that inspect
name font size and media so this one is
not working we need to override that
with important so when the styles are
not working sometimes you might need to
override that
okay like that
and
yeah let's keep going
so after the right header we're going to
target the header content
so dot header
content
and then left header
and then we're going to target the image
and then we're just also going to set
the margin
zero order
with we're going to set the same
to 90 percent
20 percent
okay so so there it is
okay
so we also need to fix the height
actually
there is an issue with the height
inspect
header
let me see if we have a height set on
the header so the height of the header
set height
is supposed to be min height so minimum
height is going to be
100 vh not the
not the fixed height so we want to be
able to scroll like this maybe
so let's go to the header
and find
header actually i'm just going to look
for 100 vh where i've said that value
100 vh so here instead of height we're
going to set that to
min height at media query actually
hit media
screen
and
max width
max width and then we're going to do 600
pixels
so this is going to be 600 pixels
let's do or 600
yeah 610 pixels
max
width
at media screen
and max width
oh
oh yeah i don't know why this is not
working
screen and oh
this is the wrong thing
cut this
put here
like this and then save and then here
we're going to say min height
100 vh
okay so you can actually do me the
queries inside of the element or element
that you want to do that's trying to
edit you can nest
only in sas that's when you can do with
normal css you cannot nest like this
okay so
it's not working
uh cancel this
let's just set that to the normal
midnight to the normal header
okay so yeah now we have the min height
everything works
okay so now let's check other pages
oh about
now let's go to the about
okay
so
let's go back to the media queries
and then
we're going to say dot about
about container
so let's look at the about container to
see which one it is
about
about about section here
about container this one that's what
we're looking at
okay so it's also a grid so we're going
to fix that above container create
templates columns
we're just going to set that to one fr
okay
and then we're going to say write about
so the right about uh we're going to say
padding top
padding top
so for the padding top i'm going to set
that to put 2.5 ram
2.5 ram so that's with the padding top
okay so
i'm also going to to set the right about
grid template columns
i'm also going to set that to one fr do
you have one only one column instead of
two
okay so now let's go to the about
okay you cannot see it yet but
everything is working we just need to
get rid of the
the paddings and everything
about container
section two
okay
so
here i'm going to get rid of the padding
so to get rid of the padding i'm uh i'm
just gonna do section select this
section
so for the padding i'm going to do
padding i'm going to say 2 ram
2.5 ram
left and right and then i'm going to
override the existing paddings
okay
so yeah as you can see it looks good so
if uh sometimes when you
do like this sometimes it doesn't
override
the old ones but now you don't need to
do it because we don't need to override
we don't need to do it
okay looks good
so now let's
let's go to the
so we need to write about let's here
let's go here we need to do the left
side so let's do left about
so for the left about i'm going to say
padding right
i want to set that to zero
and then i'm going to target the
paragraph in there and we say padding
left
i'm gonna set that to zero also
okay
okay everything looks good
all right
so uh we also need to target the
timeline
so here after here i'm just going to say
timeline
so for the timeline i'm just going to
change the grid as well
i'm going to
do just one file i just want to have one
column for the timeline as well
and then i'm just going to set the
padding
bottom to six ram
and let's save let's see what our
timeline looks like
yeah there it is it looks nice
okay
so
after that we might also
want to do the stats
okay so
let's do here after the timeline
about
stats
so in the bus stats
we're going to target the progress bars
progress pass remember the class names
and then
we're just going to do one fr
like that we want to have like a single
column
excuse me
like that everything is good
okay so now let's go to the blog section
let's see how the blogs are behaving
uh
these are the blogs
so we also want a single column in the
blogs
okay so about
and then we're just gonna say blogs
so the template columns is just putting
into a single column and then giving it
a padding bottom
from the bottom six ram
okay so
now
you see that if i go to the blogs now we
have a single column
okay everything looks good
okay so that's that
now we need to also do the contact
section
okay so
actually portfolios we missed the
portfolio so the portfolios that should
be here
portfolios so we're working on this
section now the portfolios we
want to do similar things
like here so just copy this
and put it here
okay so it's quite similar
now save let's see what we got
portfolios
there it is everything looks nice
okay
okay so we might also want to give
to this portfolio the margin top but not
yet
okay so that's pretty much everything
except the contact
contact
content
content container
okay so now let's look for the contacts
content container
okay there it is
inspect
there it's a grid
so let's keep going we need to change
the flex direction
flex direction
we're going to save column
okay so
contact
so the contact was actually a flex not a
grid
the contact container is a flex not a
grid so you need to just change the
direction of the flex
okay so yeah in there
i'm going to target the right
contact
right
contact
okay so
right contact
right contact i'm going to say imagine
left
i'm going to set that to 0
margin left 0
and then i'm going to say imagine talk
when's that to 2.5 ram so i've
experimented with these values off
camera just to make the video quicker
but you can experiment even more with
the values if you want to
okay
so yeah um that's for the right content
so if i want to target the
inspect one of these inputs
so i want to target input control
this one i want to target this so i'm
going to copy the selector copy selector
i'm going to paste it after the contact
container here
this selector so i'm looking for the
input control number two
so input control two
okay so that's the
class name it's actually
input
control two like this
ic2
that's how i've named it
so
but for this uh project i'm using i've
named it different so it's input control
too like this but in the uh the project
we did together in the video it's input
control to
input control like c i c two so here i'm
using ctrl two
okay i'm just going to say flux
direction
i'm going to put that to column
so that's for the input control 2.
and then
i'm going to target the last child of
that input control too
i'm going to say like this we use a
pseudo
selector say last child so i want to
target the last child within the input
control 2.
the last child i'm going to say margin
left
0
and then i also want margin top
excuse me
margin top so for the margin top i'm
going to say that 1.5 ram
okay
so let's go to the contact
so as you can see it's coming nice
so here inspect
this one still imagine left i'm pretty
sure we'll set that to zero
margin top
zero
it should be zero
input left
control two this one
margin left
what
control to last child
margin top
imagine left zero
what's going on
let's do this let's try that
inspect again
it seems to have a
seems to have
imagined left for some reason
last child last year last child
i don't know why it still has the
oh i think the media query is not
applied
let me refresh this again and then i'm
going to inspect
flex direction
to column
okay
so this is the last child so i'm going
to copy this selector here copy the
selector
and
cut this and replace with the one you've
copied online from the browser
okay save
okay now everything works i think it's
because of spacing you actually need to
put the spacing here so you need to
space here
space and then yeah everything will work
okay so yeah everything is working nice
everything's working fine
so now we just need to mess around with
this uh title here
okay so uh let's do that
and the title is called
actually
contact item conductor item which one is
the contact item
you know let's mess with the title first
dot
main
title
okay so here we tugging the h2
and then font size
we're going to set that to ram
and also we're going to say select this
pan
font size
2.5 frame
okay and then
dot
bg text
2.5 frame as well
font size like that now save
now let's see what we get yep so there
it is
i think we just need we might need to
increase the
this a bit let's put to three ram
okay
yep i think
so you can kind of mess around with this
the size of the font size of that
yeah so at this size is this media query
the breakpoint works really nice so
you can kind of work out what
breakpoints you need to make changes you
know i mean
so
in this case we need to fix this inspect
left header
left header
we need to set
uh
let's see header content
height
i need to set midnight i think
mean
height
or
we actually need to set the height
to 100 vh for that
for the header content
okay yeah so everything comes nice to
our breakpoint
on our breakpoint
it's actually mean height
header content we need to set min height
here
mean
height
okay so let's go to find the header
content
header content
header content
and the content that the content
so we need to set the mean height here
mean height we're going to set that to
100 vh
okay so yeah so now here we can you know
try to find some breakpoints which we
also need to
you know kind of mess around with the
styles a bit
so i think here the title is a margin
which i don't want
right header
it has a padding which i don't want
so
here we should look for right header
header
a new so here it should be actually
set the padding to zero actually
zero
refresh that
something weird is going on
yeah set is
zero and important
okay so yeah so now everything should
work nicely
you can work with the font size you can
reduce the font size at a certain width
you can use the font size percentage
okay so everything looks good
so we just need to work on a way to
let's say you can find like a breakpoint
which everything starts to break and
start you know doing some media queries
there
for example
i'll do another
breakpoint maybe
okay so
i kind of
okay contact
when does contact starts to break
okay so for this contact it breaks away
too early
so i'm going to do another breakpoint
for the contact so here
i'm going to say at media
i'm actually going to copy this
to copy this
paste it here and then here i'm going to
change this to
1432.
okay so i've experimented with these
values off camera so here the contact
breaks too early so i'm going to copy
the contact everything everything over
the contact
i'm going to cut it
and then i'm going to do that early
in this at this size at 1432
i'll paste the contact stuff here
okay so when i go to the contact
now it starts to you know
adapt early nicely
so we can also mess with the padding of
this section so in this case i'm going
to mess around with the padding of the
sections as well and once a section
i'm going to do padding
top and bottom i'm going to do 7 ram
11 ram left and right
okay so
refresh
something weird is going on
section
okay max with
let's inspect to see
the body oh the body is a class of
section so the body is in inheriting the
i mean the header is inheriting this
section styles
so in the header we need to get rid of
that
so
here i'm going to say
header
padding
zero
okay so we actually need to override
because the head is actually inheriting
the section class
okay so yeah there it is
so now when i you know start to decrease
everything is
going
slowly but
it's going to work
so let's see
okay so that's for the contact section
i'm going to do another media query
uh
i'm just going to do a middle query just
to sort of sort the padding out
so at this size uh this section
uh not at this size i'm actually going
to put another size maybe
1070
or
yeah let's do this size
1070
pixels here
i'm going to target about container
so that's the about and then grid
template columns i'm going to set that
to 1fr
and then in there i'm going to target
the right about
i'm just going to change the padding top
to 2.5 ram
2.5 frame so that's for the
top in the
uh about
so that's 1000 pixels so here there it
is so everything is going to flow nice
in a single column
okay and also i'm going to target the
main title in here
i must say main
title
x2
and then font size
for ram
span and then
for ram
let's save
okay dot pg
text
one size that's the letter for the
muscle
let's see how that's going to look like
okay we can increase that to maybe four
point five frame or six or five frame
actually
yeah
okay
i think i'll stick to 4.5
okay so that's that
you can you know sort of give like a
margin top of the coin the content here
you can give it a margin top to space it
between this
title here
so it's kind of up to you
okay so let me check
let's do the portfolio shall we
portfolios
now let's do grid template columns let's
just do
1fr
1fr so this is like two columns
okay so now we have two columns of
portfolios
and let's do the same thing for the
blogs
okay duplicate this
and change this to blogs
okay so the blog is also going to
have two columns okay like that
okay so two columns for the blogs
what do we need to mess around with
again
so yeah actually let's do one more media
query you can add me as many media
queries as you want for anything and you
can customize and change everything that
you want to change
so here i'm going to do 970
pixels
970 pixels
so here the section
section
i'm going to change the padding
something top and bottom zero seven ram
six ram
left and right
like this now let's save let's decrease
the width
so okay
yeah there it is everything looks
nice
okay
so we also need to mess with this
stuff here
when does this start to break
you know i think i might actually want
this to happen early
uh what we did with the content
the header content
header
theme button
add a content left header
about
okay i think i want this header stuff
cut to happen early so i'm going to put
that in the nine
in here in 970 i'm going to put that in
there
okay so it happens early okay like that
so i think that it makes a lot of sense
for it to happen early
then anticipate it
yeah i think that makes sense
so
we also need to do the same thing for
the controls as well
controls
cut the controls
cut that
and then we're going to make it happen
early so you can you know mess around
with the
values and see what where you want to
start you know affecting your media
queries
so i think at this size yeah i'll start
doing that at this size
okay
i might also want to space around these
ones the controls
so each control
i think i might
to imagine
i'm going to say 2 ram for this one
okay control margin to ram
okay two ram seems to be small let's see
six
it's not working for some reason
uh let's override this
still not working let's see why
control
margin oh it's top and bottom it's
supposed to be left and right
so it's supposed to be the other way
around
so let's bring it back to two ram
it's so this is top and bottom this is
left and right so i want to apply the
margin left and right
okay
so
there it is so top and bottom actually
i'm going to increase that to maybe six
point six
okay so everything's going to look nice
like this
okay so yeah you can you can kind of
mess around with everything just to kind
of
look for break points where you want to
you know affect your
your styles and elements whatever
i'm going to reduce this to 1.5
or one actually
yeah you can kind of mess around
with the media queries the breakpoints
like where your stuff starts to break
that's where you start you know
doing the media queries you can just
create a breakpoint for that
for the blogs they're breaking
quite early
so at some as some certain size you
might want to you know
put the blogs in a single
column
okay
so yeah uh
actually i'll do one more i'll do one
more i didn't want to make this video
long
i'll just do one more now
and then that's it so let's do
let's do 700 pixels
so in here this section i'm going to
change this section here just copy this
section
here we're just going to change the
padding
uh
set us to three
okay so we also want to do the about
section
about
stats let's do the stats
and then we're going to do the progress
bars
actually i think i've we've already done
the progress plus let me double check
about progress bars
yeah i think yeah we might want to
progress bars
progress bars
i think we
instead of doing the progress bars later
progress
progress pass here instead of doing it
here copy this
cut
and then we do it here
early
rather than later so here we're just you
know changing the
display of the progress bar so we're
going to have them into a single column
at 700 something pixels 700 pixels okay
so
there it is
everything looks nice
i think yeah everything looks nice so
the timeline it gets affected at 600
pixels
so
i mean i think everything is really nice
now we have the idea of how to do the
middle queries
and everything
uh we can also kind of mess around with
the main types right here
so we just need to you know set the font
size maybe to a smaller one
and then maybe we can change the
textures or the big text to a different
font size so
you can kind of mess around with the
styles to see what kind of styles you're
looking for
and what what i don't know any size you
can do any media query for inside so
yeah i think that's it for this video
so if you've learned a lot of stuff
please don't forget to subscribe
comment
and share the video
i'll see you on the next one